interesting thing about krista
is that she grew up in a town
called farmland indiana
and in farmland indiana she actually
lived on a farm that's a little on the
nose so please everyone welcome krista
hi good morning um thank you jared and
thank you everyone so much for having me
i'm krista watts
i actually grew up on a farm outside of
the town of farmland
and but i'm currently the vice dean for
operations at the united states military
academy at west point
up until about a month ago i was the
program director for the operations
research and statistics program
in the department of mathematical
sciences also at west point
um and today i'm going to kind of
interchangeably use the terms west point
and yusma my
united states military academy
synonymously
and today i want to talk a little bit
about some of the teaching and pedagogy
research that has been conducted at west
point recently
west point uh sort of has a really
unique situation where a lot of the
attributes of the academy are such that
we can create almost a randomized trial
or a cluster randomized trial in many of
our courses
um but first let's give a little
background
uh about west point itself
musema is a four-year undergraduate
institution which with approximately 4
400 students
uh all students must choose at least one
academic major this is actually a
relatively recent development so majors
were not offered at the academy for most
of its history not up until about the
1980s
and even into the 90s students weren't
required to have a major
so for instance i'm a class of 1996
graduate and my classmates could elect
to have a field of study rather than
actually majoring in a subject
all students at west point essentially
have a full ride
there's no tuition
but all students are also required to
attend all classes they must graduate
generally within four years and they
have a five-year service obligation to
the united states army upon graduation
so we don't necessarily look like a
typical liberal arts school
right outside my office um
right now is a giant howitzer field
artillery piece because it's branch week
and so literally if i walked out the
front door of my building there are
tanks and artillery pieces everywhere at
the like right now
um
so
you know but in many ways we are very
similar to other selective liberal arts
colleges we have similar admissions
rates student to faculty ratio
class size test scores racial breakdown
is pretty similar to other
schools
we have a lower
female-to-male ratio in general where we
have about 20 percent of our students
are female
we have a lower percentage of
non-resident aliens and a bit more
geographic diversity than you might see
elsewhere
uh
so what makes us suited to do this type
of research
uh first of all we have a very large
core curriculum
and so on this slide this shows you the
basic curriculum that all students must
take to graduate
uh everyone must have a minimum of 40
three credit hour or more academic
courses so if you look over here you see
that there are actually 50
courses on this slide but that includes
the seven physical education courses and
three military science courses which are
not considered as part of the 40
academic course minimum
of these 40 courses
27 of them are common courses that all
students take what we would call our
core curriculum
they have 13 required stem courses and
14 required humanities and social
science courses
now when i say they're common courses
not every student takes the exact same
courses so for instance to meet their
language requirements some students will
take portuguese other students might
take persian
students have a stronger background in
mathematics might test out a single
variable calculus and take
multi-variable calculus instead et
cetera
but you still end up with several
courses that have close to 2 000
students who take them every year and so
a thousand students that are spread out
into sections of 15 to 18 students each
and so you can do the math but that's a
lot of sections of calculus
um
and then additionally as you might
expect at a military academy the
curriculum within these courses is a bit
more standardized than you might find at
other places we tend to have a common
syllabus common text common assessments
and the student's time is also highly
structured so that can provide an
environment where we can actually test
the effects of different policies on you
know student learning or whatever we're
interested in
today i'm going to highlight three
studies that i'm personally aware of
that have been done recently but there
are many many more
and first i want to highlight the study
attribution bias in major decisions
evidence from the united states military
academy
this paper was done by among others rich
patterson who's an economist currently
at brigham young
but uh formerly a member of the
department of social sciences here at
west point and as you might guess these
first two papers were both done by
economists and they did not use r for
their statistical analysis
um
jared didn't mention stata as one of the
programs that we welcome but i'm sure
that that was included
so they define attribution bias as
instances in which individuals
misattribute the influence of a prior
temporary state to a fixed property of
their utility over a good or activity
okay what's that mean well for example
the thirst that's experienced while
you're sampling a new drink can actually
have a significant influence on a
person's stated willingness to drink it
again in the future
um and so here in this study they're
looking for attribution bias when
deciding a major in college so
specifically they test whether student
fatigue
influences a student's graduating major
at west point
so prior studies have shown that
students exhibit diminished performance
in early morning courses
and in courses that are scheduled
immediately after
one or more back-to-back courses
so this study takes advantage of the
fact that cadets schedules are randomly
assigned given their courses so once we
know what courses they're taking
the actual assignment of classes to
hours is random um it also
matters a little bit whether or not
they're division one athlete because
they usually have the afternoons or at
least one hour in the afternoon off
herewith has two major endpoints first
if being assigned to a first period
section of a required course
influences the choice to major in a
corresponding subject so for instance if
i have the core economics course first
hour am i more or less likely to choose
econ as a major
um and i should note here that first
period here starts at 7 30 in the
morning
the second end point is whether the
variation in the number of back-to-back
courses that students are assigned
immediately before a required course
influences their major choice so again
if i have econ third hour but i also
have a first and second hour class
am i more or less likely to major in
economics than if i have econ third hour
but maybe i have second hour off
um and you know i'm sure we can all
remember back to college it's a little
further back for me than probably most
of you
but i recall sitting through what seemed
like endless hours of back-to-back
courses
and there are a couple of
characteristics
about you set my i'm sorry yusma that
makes this study possible
um student time and schedules are highly
structured in their first three
semesters they're generally going to
take the same courses and they don't
really have control over the order of
the courses they take
at the time this study was conducted
courses were all 55 minutes long and
they only started at one of six times
throughout the day starting with that
early 7 30 class and going to the last
hour that starts at 305
um but courses are not actually taught
on fixed days of the week so again at
this time courses rotated and you'd have
of course monday wednesday friday of one
week
and then tuesday and thursday of the
next week so every course that you have
would be taken every day of the week
throughout the semester
um and we have had significant changes
to our schedule since this study was
conducted so if anybody's been here
recently you know these the conditions
that this study was conducted under
don't really hold any longer
um
and but particularly important to this
research is also that students aren't
allowed to change their own schedule and
so the registrar's office just down the
hall assigns the time um of day and the
instructor for each course and this can
be viewed as sort of random assignment
to course scheduling and it's a key
component of being able to do studies
like this
when the study was conducted students
declared their major during the first
semester of sophomore year
about 29 of students chose a major that
corresponds to one of the
general ed or core courses that were
taught in their first three semesters
and 83 of students graduate with the
major that they chose first in their
sophomore year um there are also pretty
strict disciplinary consequences
for missing classes so differential
attendance is not an issue here
um so we looked at almost
19 000 students from 2001 to 2017
and over 200 000 student course
observations
um
and so
i'm just gonna give you one of the
models in the interest of time
and this is the model that they fit that
looked at the question of whether having
a first hour subject influenced
a student's decision to major in a
corresponding
subject
and so here we have
y sub i c
j t s is an indicator for whether an
individual that was in course or
individual eye in course c with
professor j
during time slot s of your t chose to
major in a corresponding subject area
f of icts is an indicator whether the
course is an early morning course or not
so that's 7 30 a.m start time
exaby is a vector of student
characteristics that includes age sex
race and ethnicity s.a.t math s.a.t
verbal and leadership scores
this sum here
is a vector of the average
characteristics of a student's peers
within a course
and then you know really important to
this analysis is this course roster
fixed effect r sub i t
and that's a fixed effect for the
particular combination of courses that a
student is taking in a given semester
and due to the rigid structure of when
students take courses this roster fixed
effect sort of subsumes any
semester fixed effect
and then by comparing
outcomes of only students who share the
exact same combination of courses we can
really isolate isolate the effects of
scheduling
um this gamma c is of course fixed
effect so you know is it calculus or
world history
fee is an instructor fixed effect lambda
is a year fixed effect
um
and
these variables are intended to isolate
the fatigue that might be generated by
early morning assignment
um
and so what did we find well you're
actually 10 percent less likely to major
in a subject related to an early morning
course
and each additional course if you have
these courses that are back-to-back
immediately preceding a class reduces
the probability that students major in a
related subject by 12
um and so we we try to use this to push
back our start time a little bit of
classes but so far we're not seeing that
okay
uh the second study that i will look at
is the impact of computer usage on
academic performance and here we really
looked at more of a randomized trial
um
and this paper was done by another one
of our economist dr susan carter vice
dean for academic affairs whose office
is right through there
um
and they note that anecdotal evidence
suggests that professors and teachers
are increasingly banning laptop
computers smartphones and tablets in
their classroom
and what they did was evaluate the
effects of an experiment that randomly
allowed students access to laptop and
tablet computers during introductory
economics course
and in the interest of time let's
move on to our treatment control groups
treatment 1 students are permitted to
use laptops and tablets without
restriction
treatment too they're only permitted to
use tablets they'd be flat on their desk
and then the control
um laptop and tablet usage were
prohibited
and again there are some things here
that that
are unique to west point that really
allowed them to execute this study first
of all there's a direct link between
west point student performance and post
graduation employment so the higher
student ranks in the graduating class
that increases their chances of
receiving their first choice of military
occupation and duty location upon
graduating
and additionally all students at west
point are on equal footing in terms of
access to educational resources
so they're all required to purchase
computers and tablets or at the time and
tablets and each academic building is
equipped with wireless internet access
so they divided the classrooms into
control or one of the two treatment
groups
um
and
then they randomized the classrooms to
either control or treatment but
professors did have the discretion to
stop a student from using computer
device in any of the groups if they were
being a distraction
um and again we have this idea identical
syllabus textbook etc
and so you know again here this is the
model that we fit where y sub
ijht is the final exam
score of student i
professor j class hour h semester t
um
z jht is an indicator for an individual
being in a classroom which allowed the
laptops for tablets
x sub is the individual controls
kappa is fixed effects for each
combination of professor and semester
and lambda's fixed effects for the
combination of class hour and semester
and
so you know by concluding these semester
and professor controls we're really
comparing students within the same
semester while also controlling for the
mean difference in academic performance
and the study actually did find that
permitting computer devices in the
classroom
reduces final exam scores
and this was nearly identical for
classrooms that permitted laptops and
tablets or the classrooms that only
permitted the modified tablet usage
and this computer usage was most
detrimental to male students as well as
students who entered with a high gpa
and then the last thing that i'm going
to talk about today the third study is
the impact of
academically homogeneous classrooms for
undergraduate statistics and this was a
study conducted by our very own uh dusty
turner um and his partners in crime were
jim ployce and chris collins in
our introductory province that course we
had about 580 students across four hours
and when we talk about we talk about
sectioning by ability and i use the term
ability very loosely what we're really
talking about is prior demonstrated
academic performance um so that was our
treatment group we have throughout the
history of west point or at least you
know the last few decades
um we've kind of come and gone where at
some points
was a lot of emphasis on sectioning
viability and at some points it was
almost forbidden
um
and so here we were in an environment
where the department leadership kind of
let us do what we wanted
and
um so we had half of our our sections
were
section by ability and half a random
assignment
um we the course was only taught over
four hours
um
and so the ability was determined by
this predictive model and i'm you should
really read this article because they
put a lot of effort into
coming up with these predictive models
um and and trying to determine how well
we expect a student to do in course and
that's kind of really the interesting
part uh maybe but it's not what i'm
talking about so you should read the
article or talk to dusty afterwards
um and but they considered the previous
math courses taken and academic program
scores but not every instructor was
assigned to both treatment and control
so for instance i only taught one
section so i was only assigned to the
treatment group
and then they analyzed the grade on
um coursewide graded events so exams and
um
and our final
here's um
a breakdown they looked at a few
different endpoints but here we see in
red the randomly assigned sections and
in blue the ability group sections and
these you know randomly assigned
sections where
they are are
spinning them
by what ability group they would have
been in and you know i think you can
just look at this graph and see it
doesn't look like there's a whole lot
going on here not a lot of difference
between um the red and the blue
and you know that's what they found
there was no difference in the average
grade between groups um
there was no difference you know at any
ability level so
maybe we we thought well maybe it helps
students who are at lower abilities or
help students who are at higher
abilities but it really didn't and even
when they controlled for
the average grade um the predicted grade
still no difference in average grade
i will tell you though that i personally
prefer teaching a group that's more
academically homogeneous it's much
easier to prepare and sort of relate to
to a group like that but
turns out maybe the students don't
actually fear better
uh so here are my references uh these
were the first first two talks first two
studies i mentioned
um
and then this third or sorry yeah the
third study from
dustian cohort
um so
thank you very much um
i will
you know i hope that you enjoyed the
talk and you can get a hold of me and
let me know if you have any questions
thanks
great
thank you very much for being here
hopefully you'll be able to stick around
and um
check out some of the other talks
we are now ready for our next presenter